the new 2020 Dell XPS 13 might look
pretty much identical to the 2019 XPS 2
and 1
but there are some substantial
differences I'm actually really
surprised so today we're gonna be
comparing these two laptops we're gonna
look at the displays the speakers the
keyboards and trackpads
even things like performance and
thermals and I'll help you decide which
one of these laptops you should get
let's start out with the exteriors the
design is very very similar but the new
XPS 13 is actually slightly smaller you
can see the width is pretty much the
same but it is smaller and it is
actually slightly thinner as well just
as very small difference now if you look
at the back you will notice that there
is a difference in the hinges the new
XPS 13 does have an all aluminum hinge
compared to the last year's model but
the two on one as you guys could tell by
the name is a convertible laptop so you
can actually fold the display all the
way back where the keyboard and then the
keyboard shuts off there's actually a
nice little magnet that will keep the
screen there and they could just use a
touchscreen either horizontally like
this or you can use it vertically so if
you want your laptop to work as a tablet
you can only get that with the two and
one but honestly I have almost never
used it like this it's fairly heavy for
a tablet at about 2.8 5 pounds and it
just doesn't feel comfortable holding
like this with all the keys and the
trackpad here clicking and along with
that there is no windows hello on this
laptop so right now to login you need to
find a little fingerprint scanner there
we go and we're in not only do we have
the same really nice fingerprint sensor
that's built into the power button I
like on the two and one
in the previous XPS but Dell has brought
back the Windows hello facial
recognition just like that you open it
up it logs you in now one pleasant
surprise with the 2020 XPS 13 is that
the hinge is now a one-handed open as
you guys could see previously it was way
too stiff with a two and one
it starts out easily and then it
actually gets much stiffer and then you
can't finish opening it you have to use
it with two hands and you would think
that maybe that's done just for the
touchscreen so to keep it more stable
but this one is actually more stable
even though it's easier to open if I
shake my table here
see that the two-in-one screen actually
moves around more now before we talk
about keyboards and trackpad let me show
you some other differences externally
let's flip these two over there's
definitely some differences in cooling
and design so at the top here we have
these vertical slots compared to these
horizontal ones here and then on the
sides the two and one actually has three
smaller ones compared to two longer ones
now the bottom ones are used for
speakers we'll talk about that in just a
bit there are some differences top one
is used to suck in air flow the new XPS
it actually has a little bit more curved
sort of like a MacBook over here so that
when you put them on your lap there is
less chances of these vents and the
speaker's being blocked it has a little
bit better access to air flow which is
great now the ports are absolutely
identical we have two Thunderbolt three
ports both full-speed that's also used
for charging and we have the micro SD
card slot over here and then a headphone
jack now the shape of the track pads are
slightly different but as far as the
feel and the quality they are basically
the same now as far as the keyboards
you'll see that we have page up and page
down on the sides whereas the new XPS it
actually builds that into the the up and
down key so you have to hold a function
button now you might be able to also
notice that this keyboard is actually
recessed a little bit more so than the
two-in-one and that is because the new
XPS 13 for 2020 has more key travel
actually has a little bit more feedback
at the same time so the two and one has
a decent keyboard it feels good most
you'll be happy but the new XPS 2020
does feel better when Dell launched the
new XPS two and one it was very
impressive for a number of reasons first
off they redesigned it but the bigger
reasons were that they put in a new
Intel tenth generation processors with
new graphics faster RAM all that stuff
is in this laptop but another big thing
is that they showed off their vapor
chamber cooling system with two fans on
the sides in this big chamber to make
sure it ran cool and quiet now I was
really surprised when I opened up this
new XPS and I did not find that vapor
chamber inside of there we still have
two fans which is great the heatsink is
connected the fans are just
it's but they're not using the chamber
and that was very odd and that got me
thinking is our cooling performance and
overall performance gonna be worse with
this new laptop we'll take a look at
that in just a bit but another thing
that I saw is that we still have a
replaceable SSD that is something you do
not get with the two on one even though
the slightly heavier slightly larger and
the your SSD is solder so whatever you
buy out of the factory out of the gate
that is what you're stuck with with this
one you can go ahead and open it up pull
out SSD you know even if you buy the
base model put in a 1 terabyte or a 2
terabyte later and that is one huge
benefit of the new XPS 13 for 2020 now
let's talk about the displays they are
almost identical
they're both 4k resolution actually
slightly higher than 4k because these
are not sixteen by nine displays they
are 16 by 10 so you have a little bit
more pixels vertically which is great
for 13-inch laptops they're both around
4k they're both around 500 nits which is
excellent but the new XPS for 20/20
looks like it's a little bit less
reflections when I move around back and
forth compared to the two on one so we
might have better coatings which is a
good thing but either way they're both
excellent looking both very nice and
sharp now let's go ahead and test out
the speakers
[Music]
alright guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below
especially if you use a pair of
headphones now I am very happy that the
new XPS 20/20 is louder that has always
been a complaint of mine with a lot of
decks XPS laptops and actually looked
into the specs and the two and one uses
two watt speakers one on each side
whereas this one uses two and a half
watt speakers one on each side and it
definitely kicks it up and as far as
volume on average is about two decibels
louder so that is a great thing the
quality sound it's very similar to me
and keep in mind you guys are listening
through a microphone through compression
all of that stuff but I would definitely
take the improvement in loudness both of
these laptops use 720p webcam so this is
the quality of the two and one both
video and microphone and this is the
webcam and microphone quality of the
2020 XPS 13 let me know if any
differences that you guys notice down in
the comments section below now let's
talk about performance both of these
laptops have Intel's 10th generation
processors they have i7s with g7
graphics and we're gonna see if the
cooling differences are gonna matter
when we start pushing these machines
let's go ahead and run Cinebench to
their CPU tests between my two machines
here there is a difference in RAM I have
16 gigs over here and 32 gigs for the
two and one now you can get both of
these with 32 and the results are in and
this is interesting the new XPS actually
scores quite a bit higher in single core
whereas the two on one actually scores
higher in multi-core I'm guessing that
is because of RAM now let's go ahead and
test out the graphics performance we
have over 10,000 on both this is
incredibly high the previous XPS is
we're about 5 to 6 thousand so excellent
scores you can't really go wrong and I'm
also curious about thermals because this
isn't really pushing it to the limits so
let's go ahead and run Unigine Heaven
which is a gaming test it's gonna push
the graphics to the max and then we'll
see what happens
once again interesting the new XPS is
actually scoring slightly higher and it
was actually slightly quieter as well as
far as fan noise so I really makes me
you think does that vapor chamber
cooling really help that much is that
really making the difference or is maybe
that's why they got rid of it for the
new one because it actually didn't let's
go ahead and just push this to its max
as far as the CPU
let's run Cinebench our 20 and let's see
what happens with our temperatures in
our thermals
so as we're testing here this is very
interesting the two on one is actually
running at about 20 watts whereas the
new XPS 2020 is running about 25 watts
as far as temperatures the new one is
actually running hotter about a hundred
degrees Celsius
but the fans are quieter whereas the two
and one it's running at about eighty
degrees Celsius or so and running cooler
but also running a little bit louder so
that is very interesting and then
towards the end of the test the two and
one is very consistent whereas the new
XPS actually slowed down and lower the
CPU wattage to fifteen and then that got
the CPU to be cooler as well and then
now that we're done looking at these
scores the new XPS is actually quite a
bit higher in terms of performance that
is something that I did not expect so it
looks like the new cooling system it is
running slightly hotter but it's also
accepting way more wattage might be just
a software tweak and the performance is
better and then the fans a little bit
quieter as well so interesting overall
the new XPS 2020 is slimmer it's a
little bit lighter it performs better
it's slightly quieter does run hotter it
has a better keyboard trackpad is very
similar and you can also switch out the
SSD on this one so if you're somebody
that does not need this hinge which I
think most people probably don't you
guys let me know your thoughts down in
the comment section I would probably say
that I would go for the new XPS 13 two
and one the speaker difference is nice
the keyboard definitely feels better as
well I just did a little more typing
with it now the only thing comes down to
is prices right now you can get a little
bit of discounts on this two on one
because it's been out longer so if the
price is similar I would say go for this
one if you're getting this the XPS 2 and
one for a lot cheaper you might want to
go for it but overall I would have to
the wind definitely to the 2020 XPS 13
thank you guys for watching if you want
to see the full review of this we will
have a little video right over there
you guys can click that circle above to
subscribe and if you need a website
definitely go and check out Squarespace
this Ben Max and I will see you in the
next video
[Music]